how many of the tables in your data
warehouse have location information in
them
perhaps you record the latitude and
longitude of your vehicles or packages
over time or maybe you have the
addresses of your customers and
suppliers
maybe you recorded customer transactions
and you could join it against another
table that has store locations not only
is location information very common many
business decisions revolve around
location who to send out coupons to
whether the package will reach on time
therefore geospatial analysis is quite
common in data analytics 9% of dot
sequel files and github carry out
spatial queries that's why I'm happy to
show you a new feature that makes
analyzing and visualizing geospatial
data in bigquery very easy and highly
performant Det and daily is a public
data set of weather data and the
station's table contains latitude and
longitude columns in another table I
have information about postal codes used
by the United States Postal Service
there are two columns in this table that
are of interest here
the wkt or well-known text is a format
for representing geographies in this
case it is a polygon the postal code
called the zip code is the second column
that we're interested in so let's run a
query that finds all the weather
stations within 10 kilometers of a zip
code I'm pulling the zip code polygon
and the weather station location and
then in my where clause I'm filtering
using st underscore d within distance
with them i'm checking whether the
station's latitude and longitude which
form a geographic point whether that
point is within 10 kilometers of the zip
code
and if you look at the results there are
two stations that are inside the polygon
itself so the distance is zero and there
are 28 total stations within 10
kilometers of the zip code this is great
but if you have spatial data you want to
visualize it you want to visualize it on
a map the bigquery geo vez is a
convenient way to do this so here I have
the same query in the Geo vez I can
select the geometry column and then
click run to get a map of the weather
stations I can also style the points
based on some other column in the data
here's another query that shows of the
ability to style things in the map this
time I'm joining the Census data set of
population with zip code boundaries
let's make the polygon column the wkt
column the geography and change the
colors and opacity of the polygons based
on population
as you can see bigquery GIS provides a
convenient powerful way to incorporate
spatial information into your
decision-making even as your datasets
grow into the petabytes
[Music]